and then we're gonna make a bunch of
clips and funny thumbnails oh yeah we're
gonna you we're gonna cut up into
clickbait all those times you were like
this oh yeah poor selfie Russian soldier
thing is the one video that never left
me like it's always stuck with me gaming
nightmares it was the most like
horrifying video serated night agar and
just saw it as [ __ ] name while he was
alive yeah like that's like there's the
fact there's people that like want to
see that we wanted to see it but we were
like we was like 16 years old though
maybe that was the [ __ ] audience he
was on those websites yeah there were
like [ __ ] the FBI arrested a whole like
there has to be like I don't know if
it's 50 or 200 but in any amount is
plenty yeah of guys that had paid like
they were paying like three or four
hundred dollars a month to be a part of
a website where a father was molesting
his daughter oh man who was eight until
she was like 12 or 13 and they
eventually got bust and they just busted
all these guys who had been paying like
400 bucks a month for like two years
and this guy's like once a week he does
a video where he like goes into his
daughter's room and oh my Coleman like
home and you this guy was in there not
not I never knew who the guy was no but
their sky they paid for the guys that
were paying so I paid for to you it like
some guy he's like who's some guy who
paid to you know 500 bucks or four and a
bus for like a year and a half or six
months or three months and these guys
are getting like seven-year sentences
five years sentences and they're like
and they wish it you could be behind
them like in line you're sitting there
waiting to get your child and you hear
like two guys like this is [ __ ] and
I know I'm gonna
like 20,000 dollars in restitution to
this girl I mean it's ridiculous I mean
I was only on I only paid for four
months and you're sitting there thinking
they're like I didn't do nothing you
were paying someone to rape his daughter
and you're pissed because now you have
to if she's like there's tons of those
guys so there's people that will watch
all kinds of weird stupid ridiculous
so beyond [ __ ] up I can't even [ __ ]
a man ever seen bumfights damn bumfights
yeah yeah that was on when I when I was
out and I used to watch that I used to
watch bang bus everyone said ridiculous
wait about deer see backroom facials
nobody I surfed it I surfed at this
Beach Oh captain Stabbin yeah captain
Stabbin what the [ __ ] was that like a
dude on a pirate ship basically I saw I
was in when I was in Mexico at surfing
at this weird secluded beach break and
on the cliff was this big mansion and
the dudes like oh yeah that was the guy
who started I forget the name of it now
it was the college girls topless with oh
the dude who started girls gone wild his
mansion was on the hill there and it was
like Alison Alison Arnold was in and one
of the girls gone Wow whatever happened
to that guy the guy I know yeah there
was a whole thing with him and Paris
Hilton and something yeah is he free now
didn't he get in trouble for discipline
well something some of the girls were
like underage or something like that he
got busted I think it was something like
that I don't know oh Sh out to our
sponsor Bud Light by the way shout out
the Bud Light Newports no not them but
me do you really have a sponsor with Bud
Light maybe we do maybe we don't my god
star - we're speaking it into existence
Jack Daniels supreme Rumple Minze
are some people still watching this yeah
somebody is excited that we mentioned
captain Stabbin
man there's 277 people watching right
now 277 that's a lot of peers that P is
anybody in the chat ever heard of fax
verse it's a YouTube channel and the
star of the YouTube channel is sitting
at this table right now 8 million
subscribers a million subscribers the
best place on the internet to find out
information and entertainment you will
not be disappointed
live show every Thursday at 1:00 p.m.
fax fax verse yes first yeah okay and
verse we they specialize we specialize
in infotainment to just let you guys
know like top tens about crazy things
that people used to do for hygiene in
the Middle Ages or 10 things you didn't
know about Paris Hilton's shoe size it's
just great stuff that you can tune in
learn a lot about and always have
something to talk about
and we do a live show every Thursday at
1:00 1:00 p.m. it's the best live stream
show on the internet that streams at
1:00 p.m. every Thursday be there get
the live chat and drop the kind of money
that you're dropping right now we might
not have Matt Cox but we got me and
that's it that's all you need is it
YouTube or is it time to twitch okay
it's YouTube Luke goes on there any
talks he like responds to comments and
he does he posts his own animation show
that he started where it's like yeah
it's like part it's like really cool he
makes these sick collages where he cuts
like people out of like fashion
magazines and he cuts out the mouth
holes and the eye holes and he puts his
own mouth and eyes and he creates these
sick animations that they're funny as
[ __ ] you want to see an episode you show
to him it's called lames it's pretty
good you know who hey what's the of real
estate guy that he been he interviewed
Ben you had him on your podcast Oh
Graham Graham Graham I was thinking
about Connor I wonder if I don't think
he would do no no okay that's this point
he's like I mean he's very it's it's
very real estate like
what's up guys smash that like button
yeah yeah he's a youtuber yeah yeah he's
definitely he's super nice guy though
yeah great guy
check out this fine arts full screen
that thing
[Music]
[Music]
it's a show based on Shane two stories
[Music]
look at that he's posting that and he
doesn't have a million subscribers yet
groundbreaking animation breaking
moaning hold it surprise roll a comedy
on what up your boy what I need right
now is a Matt Cox fine arts degree
review of what you just saw are you
walking away from the table okay you got
a small bladder think about that answer
are you in three times we're about to
lose all our viewers
[Laughter]